the sg1 Creator Brad Wright's been
talking about how rules in sci-fi matter
and that got me so just warm and tingly
inside I do look bad right welcome to
site track your Sci-Fi TV and movie
channel
[Music]
but Brad white has been talking about
one of the big reasons why Stargate was
so consistently brilliant
the rules
they established a set of rules at the
beginning of sg1 and then they mostly
followed them
or at very least if they broke them they
came up with a good reason why Brad
Wright actually talks about how in fact
the rules that they establish are what a
lot of the stories then come from for
example the Stargate can only open for
38 minutes
how many times did that then create
really interesting stories for the SGC
them being attacked but your enemy
because they've got a proper DHD could
dial in faster than you could so they
kept holding the gate open and stopping
us from escaping or we dial into a black
hole and all of a sudden it's locked in
to an endless power supply those rules
created so many interesting stories and
sometimes when those rules were then
broken or bent it was done with a good
reason with a plan maybe some techno
Babble but it was always done with some
consistency
now this actually comes from a companion
article there is a link in the
description to go over to the companion
and particularly to listen to the audio
version of this article he wrote this
some time ago but the Articles this way
are a new thing for the companion please
go and check it out and have a listen
Brad really does talk about a lot of
really fascinating examples of why he
thinks sometimes those rules in things
like Star Trek and Star Wars have
affected the story now I am also a
trackie Star Trek was my first love but
you know then Stargate came and stole my
heart
but Star Trek was my first love and Star
Trek at times infuriates me but we keep
being told by trekkies that we shouldn't
worry too much about Canon when they
change these rules don't stress it it's
still Star Trek and All Star Trek is
brilliant Star Trek now I'm disagree I
think Canon and the rules do matter if
you establish something very clearly in
an episode then that becomes gospel and
if you're going to then break it you
better have a good reason
in the article that I'm talking about
Brad Wright mentions to JJ Abrams movies
where all of a sudden you could beam
because Scotty just thought it up from a
planet to a vessel already very far away
while it's traveling at Warp that's a
nonsense Transporters are only good from
basically very short ranges from orbit
to the land they do not do light years
then in the second Star Trek movie Khan
beamed himself from a little shuttle I
don't know how powerful that shuttle was
but it must have added one hell of a
battery
and he beamed himself all the way to
Kronos the Klingon Homeworld halfway
across the Galaxy
again an absolute nonsense why are we
bothering with Starships if that is
possible
they never bothered really to explain
how that was possible other than Scotty
came up with some calculations
that's a nonsense now the JJ Abrams
people will say well this is a different
Universe though this is a different set
of rules
but that's just a cop-out and it's lazy
Brad Wright's talking about how that is
really the difference between Science
Fiction and Fantasy now Star Wars is
more fantasy but he then also points out
though that in the one of the later Star
Wars movies one of the one of the
Republic vessels turn around and shoots
into and that big massive vessel and
wipes that an entire Armada of Empire
vessels by hitting it at Warp
he points out why didn't they do that
sooner why didn't they do that when I
don't know battling the Death Star they
had loads of vessels Edge just shoot one
of them into it at light speed
it's problem solved you wouldn't even
need if you planned ahead to have
anybody on board you could computer
program it so if actually hitting an
enemy vessel at light speed is such a
devastating weapon why wasn't it used
previously
so if you're going to do something very
clever like that that looks pretty at
least explain it or it really does make
a nonsense of it being sci-fi now Star
Wars isn't sci-fi it's way more fantasy
than it is sci-fi but it's still
should have some rules to it and when
those rules are broken because we're not
completely thick it frustrates us now
all the trekkies that say Canon doesn't
matter it really is again a bit of a
cop-out you're giving the creators of
the new track an excuse to do what they
want now occasionally new Trek actually
emphasizes this point they will make a
little comment they'll have them make
even a little joke out of the fact that
like Spock is now completely different
in things like this
to me though it's just frustrating I'm
trying really hard to ignore a lot of
the rule breaking in Star Trek I even
did a video a couple of weeks ago saying
look let's just pretend it's not really
Star Trek it's Star Trek 2.0 and that
way all of these errors and all of these
changes to Canon just don't matter
because it's not really Star Trek
anymore
but even that to be honest is giving
them an out they should set up these
rules and they then should stick to them
and when they then break them come up
with a good reason why because it makes
brilliant stories
it's not that difficult if you plan
ahead now with the new Stargate series
if we believe the rumors that um we've
been hearing Mark Fergus and hawcostby
are planning to develop this series and
one of the things they've been doing now
for months is establishing a set of
rules that is the Bible and a timeline
that the new creators will then stick to
apparently Amazon have given them
permission to bend the rules in a few
places and to change a few things that
fit the storyline
but I am reassured
that assuming these rumors are true
the talk hostby and Mark Fergus are
thinking the same way as Brad Wright
that is so so important to establish
those rules at the outset
and then to try very hard not to break
them like Brad Wright almost did and the
very first episode pretty much the first
scene of sg1 he said that the gate is
basically one way that was a rule that
was established in the movie and one
that they agreed now they created some
addendums for those rules they basically
said look radio waves because it has no
Mass they can travel two-way brilliant
very clever but Mata cannot travel two
way through the Stargate
unfortunately when poffice and his men
arrived in the very open sequence of
children of the Gods the gate stayed
open
they attacked the SGC and they kidnapped
a few flight officers they then turned
around and walked back through the gate
Brad writing code didn't even realize
their error until they were in the
editing Suite so then they had to sort
of like throw together a bit of a scene
where we see a prophets ordering like a
mobile DHD and they had to sort of like
figure it out that way and he said it
never sat right the scene doesn't fit
the flow of the overall scene and it
really stuck out like a sort of thumb
but thank God they at least realized it
or Brad Wright was saying we'd have
actually ruined one of the most
important rules straight away
but Patrick did catch it and did think
it was important enough to actually fix
I'm kind of wishing some of the guys
from Star Trek could be so
detail-orientated and actually when an
error is realized
fix it
but unfortunately
a moments at least they don't bother so
much instead the Star Trek fans have to
come up with excuses and reasons why the
mistake still make sense but hey it
gives us Chucky something to do that we
have to figure out ways to make your
mistakes make sense
thanks very much
please go over to the companion and
check out the full interview not only
does it give you an insight into Brad
Wright the creator of one of the
greatest TV shows ever made but also it
really should give you an idea of what
sci-fi should be and why sci-fi at the
moment is a little bit um
and why some of the Sci-Fi we're
watching at the moment is so frustrating
because they don't follow the rules
right actually says at one point that he
thinks he could create a really Kick-Ass
Star Trek or Star Wars script that fit
the rules that have been established and
was still excited if only they'd let him
if only they'd let him
but guys what do you think about this
idea that rules actually do matter and
when they get broken for no good reason
it's just frustrating does it matter new
or do you think no look calm down
don't worry about Canon too much let's
just have good stories is that more
important than Canon get into the cons
to tell me exactly what you're thinking
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe with that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you can follow all these links in the
Stream across the bottom here they're in
the description too for all really good
Sidetrack stuff including the patreon
account where you get to see most of our
videos first and for a small fee each
month it really supports the channel you
get to see them without the adverts and
you can even get a free gift can't say
fairer than that
as always goes please stay safe and I'll
see you next time
foreign
[Music]